good morning believe nation it's time to
step up it's time to think bigger it's
time to believe that you can be a game
changer and I'm gonna share an inspiring
clip from Ron Finley that I think Wow
I'm Ron Finley I'm ecolution Airy
renegade gangsta provocateur
game-changing Gardner so Ron Finley is
fairly new to me he was just introduced
to me recently by one of you guys here
on YouTube and I love the way he
introduces himself he calls himself a
renegade a gangster a game changer and
then he says Gardner and the first you
might think what a gangster
game-changing renegade Gardner but I
love the way that he introduces himself
you see he's in one of the oldest
industries there is gardening it's been
done for centuries and finally the
somebody stepping up making a mark and
trying to have a big impact if he can be
a gangster renegade game-changing
gardener why can't you be a game-changer
in your industry the first step is you
have to actually believe that you are a
renegade that you will change the game
because if you don't really believe deep
down that you're a game changer then
there's no way anybody else is gonna
believe it and then there's no way
you're actually gonna change the game so
step up be proud be a renegade via
gangster be a game changer and believe
in yourself thank you for watching my
question of the day today is do you
believe that your game changer and if
not what's holding you back what are the
limiting personal beliefs you have that
make you feel like you're not a game
changer I love to hear it leave a
comment below thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events preso